now a twelve-year-old girl called
Genesis Butler has challenged the Pope
to go vegan for Lent and if he does he
will get 1 million dollars for the
charity of his choice as she's written
an open letter that's been published in
The Guardian today and in other
newspapers across the globe we'll hear
more about her letter in just a moment
but let's have a listen to her we're
asking for Pope Francis help to protect
our planet by drawing attention to the
devastating impact of animal agriculture
if he agrees to go Platt bass will give
1 million dollars to the charity of his
choice
well that was Genesis butler and her
appealed to the Pope with me now Matthew
Glover who is behind this challenge and
Jane lamb the co-founder on 4 January
welcome to you both and this is
interesting why do you wanna get the
Pope involved in the vegan movement
well Pope Francis we know cares about
climate change we know he cares about
compassion for animals he wrote his
encyclical in 2015 Lord outer sea where
he talked about the tyrannical use abuse
of animals so we know that this is
something that's very close to his heart
but what he may not know is that animal
agriculture is a leading cause of
climate change a leading cause of
biodiversity and species extinction so
we're asking him to take leadership on
this subject and consider trying vegan
for Lent which is a period of time which
Christians and Catholics are used to
going abstaining from certain products
Jade is interesting because with the
Pope comes 1.2 billion Catholics
across the globe and perhaps more what
would be the environmental impacts of
converting all of those people to a
plant-based diet it would be huge I mean
we know that when the Pope does
something people listen the statistics
that we've that were using in the
letters so it's 8 currently 83 percent
of the world's land use is to go to
animal agriculture yet it produces just
18 percent of our calories now the
statistics about the flight it's just
escaped to me but math you might have
this one yeah so basically the
environmental impact during Lent if
everybody in the world was to go vegan
for Lent 40 days yeah well yeah 40 days
then it's the equivalent of Germany not
emitting any co2 for a whole year so it
would be massive and so you think the
effects of 1.2 billion people going to a
plant-based diet would be positive and
that's obviously because of the
controversy that surrounds intensive
meat and dairy farming but by getting
1.2 billion people on to a plant-based
diet there's intensive farming that
comes with producing enough crops for
people to eat as well and we're also
talking about you know a lot of
pesticides and erosion of soil
degrading of the quality of sauce so it
has negative impacts as well if 1.2
billion people plus switched to a
plant-based diet yeah now that the
reality is that around about as Jane
said it's like an 8020 rule so the
majority of land is used either for
grazing animals off a growing products
growing food to feed to animals so we
would only need about 25% of the land
that we currently use if everybody was
on a plant-based diet so we could give
land back to nature so we could reforest
now if you could then REE wild and
reforest these all over the world then
that would those trees would take carbon
out the atmosphere so people's personal
greenhouse gas emissions would reduce by
around about 30 to 50 percent by being
plant-based so it's a real solution for
climate change is it anymore about
balance though Jane because I'm you know
whatever way converting people you know
billions of people to a plant-based diet
you aren't going to have to come up with
more crops and the way of the world is
you have to use intensive farming you
can't be organic and dig by hand all
farming processes involve machinery and
emissions pesticides and all of that so
you're sort of swapping like for like
would it not be better to encourage
people to go 5050 and perhaps cut back
in one area and take up more in another
the reality is that actually animals are
eating these crops so they're not being
fed directly to humans
so if we were not feeding those crops to
humans sorry to animals we would have an
extra 1 billion tons of food to feed
people it's really inefficient way of
eating so instead of going to the source
we're actually filtering it through an
animal it's like going to your fridge
taking out templates of food and
throwing 9 away effectively that is what
we're doing when we're funneling our
calories through an animal it's
interesting the vegan movement is huge
at the moment of course we've just come
out of a vegan area where a lot of
people have tried it and you know I'm
sure a few people are going to carry on
being vegan as a result of trying it and
but the vegan movement can get quite a
bad name when it comes to some
protesters we've seen images here on Sky
News of vegan protesters going into
restaurants and supermarkets with
distressing images and harassing
customers to to come round
to their way of thinking does this
damage the cause for you Murphy yeah I
mean we understand how a lot of the
vegan activist how they feel we don't
necessarily condone those actions and
that's why with this campaign it's very
much a mainstream campaign where we're
directing it to His Holiness Pope
Francis and giving him an opportunity to
take leadership on this important
subject and we would ask him as well
just in terms of how we treat animals at
the moment you know what would Jesus say
about factory farming and the intensive
way that animals are reared what would
you what would you used to say about
slaughterhouses you know we'd ask him
and all the Catholics and Christians to
really think about that have you had any
response from the Vatican yet not as yet
it's early days early days but just on
that as well I think our campaign what
we launched and you can see with our
adverts you can see with our publicity
it's a very positive it's a supportive
campaign we're not just encouraging Pope
Francis we're encouraging everyone to
give vegan a go for Lent they didn't do
it for began you this is the second time
to do it we have got a website and we've
got a really comprehensive vegan starter
kit that people can download and it
gives them all the help and guidance
they need